so freunde fastenzeit eine wunderbare
gelegenheit mal über ekel essen in
deutschland zu sprechen ja lidl zum
beispiel lidl musste gerade eine
bestimmte sorte blätterteig zu rückrufen
wegen ich zitiere metall fremdkörpern
können sie übrigens ganz leicht testen
ob die croissants die sie aus dem teig
gebacken haben betroffen sind die gründe
treffer treffer außerdem ist hier nur
ein
ein beispiel es kommen ja praktisch
täglich solche ekel essen meldungen
außerdem hatten wir gerade plastikteile
im joghurt fipronil in eiern und
hepatitis a in choco datteln laut einer
laut einer neuen foodwatch studie werden
viele lebensmittel skandale zwar von den
deutschen behörden aufgedeckt aber jetzt
kommt wir konsumenten erfahren in der
regel nichts
ekel brot in bayerischen großbäckereien
grau grün und weiß pigmentierter
schimmelpilz befall mäusekot und der
verbraucher erfuhr auch davon zunächst
nichts
schimmel schaden mäusekot warte man das
rezept muss ich mir auch schreibt ja
gerade bei backwaren meine damen und
herren lohnt es sich oft mal genauer
hinzugucken hier
das sieht aus wie ein kürbis kern
brötchen wenn wir aber ran zoomen war
immer so lecker proteine
tatsächlich gibt es ein
transparenzgesetz dass unsere behörden
eigentlich verpflichtet missstände zu
veröffentlichen aber aus angst vor
klagen der firmen tun sie es einfach
nicht in der praxis das thema liegt seit
vier jahren in karlsruhe beim
bundesverfassungsgericht aber es gibt
noch nicht mal ein verhandlungstermin
unterarme deutsche es ist inzwischen
schon völlig abgestumpft
ja ich denke wie jeder mensch also
irgendwann kommt natürlich mal vor einer
dönerbude dass man mal danach sich
übergeben musste
wie resigniert er das ja sehr schöne
neue zdf-serie übrigens demnächst weiter
übrigens übrigens könnten unsere
bundesländer auch viel mehr tun und
veröffentlichen aber nur in northeim
nordrhein westfalen gibt es das
entsprechende gesetz die sogenannte
hygiene ampel
ja da steht dann außenanlagen dran wie
sauber ist drin ist das hat in den pilot
städten duisburg und bielefeld die
hygiene um 70 prozent verbessert ist gut
konsequenterweise schafft die neue
schwarz-gelbe landesregierung in
düsseldorf das gesetz jetzt im märz
wieder ab und dann werden die kontrollen
wieder laschet lasse